knapp eine autostunde von tel aviv
entfernt
hier sollte dieser esc eigentlich
stattfinden
ein politisch hoch sensibler ort wenn
die heilige stadt wird von israelis und
palästinensern zugleich als hauptstadt
beansprucht aber das war es nicht was
den veranstalter ewu den europäischen
rundfunk verband dazu bewog den esc nach
tel aviv zu verlegen
es hätte nicht mal annähernd genügend
hotelzimmer gegeben um die presse die
delegation die fans unterzubringen auch
die halle dort war problematischen hätte
große herausforderungen dargestellt und
letztlich haben die beiden gründe schon
den ausschlag gegeben obwohl das
natürlich auch noch die thematik der
ultraorthodoxen gab die darauf bestanden
hätten
dass wir freitag samstag nicht arbeiten
was natürlich schwierig ist bei einer
live sendung die samstagabend
ausgestrahlt wird
israels regierungschef benjamin
netanyahu hätte den esc schon aus
symbolischen gründen lieber in jerusalem
gesehen doch angesichts der schabbat
frage akzeptierte er das e voting
tel aviv hat eine sehr starke präsenz
also wird das ein starker sc
tatsächlich ist der schabbat der heilige
samstag für den esc ein echtes problem
sogar in tel aviv der liberalen schwulen
freundlichen küstenstadt
[Musik]
eltern schwarz ist tel avivs oberster
pr-berater und so etwas wie der esc
generalbevollmächtigter der stadt
er schlägt sich mit einer ganzen reihe
von schwierigkeiten herum
so gibt es zu wenige hotels für die
14.000 gäste und die restaurantbesitzer
drohen mit streik doch die größte hürde
ist auch hier der schabbat denn das esc
finale findet an einem samstag statt
und dann fahren selbst in tel aviv keine
busse der bürgermeister wird nächste
woche verkünden dass es an beiden tagen
kostenlose shuttlebusse geben wird damit
jeder zum expo gelände kommt das wäre
also gelöst
das sind alles dinge mit denen sich die
stadt vor dem esc auseinandersetzen muss
aber ich denke wir finden lösungen
der optimist schwarz sieht den esc trotz
aller schwierigkeiten als chance er will
tel aviv als event statt positionieren
für religiöse juden hingegen ist es ein
absolutes tabu am schabbat zu arbeiten
nun soll ausgerechnet für den esc mit
den heiligen geboten gebrochen werden
denn vorbereitungen und proben werden
den ganzen samstag dauern
[Musik]
hoher rabbiner sind darüber verärgert
wie elisa weiß rabbi in der 30
generation und mitglied des oberrabbiner
rates in unserem ruhetag verzichten wir
auf alles technische wie handys oder
telefone aber auch auf alle äußeren
quellen der ablenkung und unterhaltung
wir sitzen beieinander und singen aber
wir hören keine musik wir sehen auch
nicht fern und wir besuchen keine
konzert ist der tag an dem wir in uns
gehen und an dem wir uns an der
herrlichkeit der göttlichen schöpfung
erfreuen
es ist ein ruhetag und dieser ruhetag
ist heilig gabi weiss und andere
geistliche versuchten auf die regierung
einzuwirken um den esc zu verschieben
doch sie konnten nichts ausrichten die
organisatoren der eu blieben hart
dummerweise haben wir 45 länder die
samstags abends zur hauptsendezeit
dieses format eingeplant haben solche
formate werden monate im vorhinein aus
blockiert der sendetermin auch für 2020
steht jetzt schon fest und ist in den
planungen der sender das wäre technisch
und organisatorisch unmöglich gewesen
und es wäre immer ein samstag gewesen
weil das halt die beste europäische
wendezeit ist fängt getankt
das zeugt von ignoranz und von
mangelndem verständnis für die
empfindlichkeiten anderer leute
ich weiß nicht ob es praktisch gewesen
wäre das auf einen dienstag mittwoch und
donnerstag zu verschieben
diese organisation sollte die
kulturellen eigenheiten der länder in
denen sie zu gast ist was in einem land
zu gast ist muss ich auch an die regeln
halten
immerhin eines konnten die geistlichen
erreichen der schabbat bruch findet
wenigstens nicht in jerusalem statt
denn dort leben tausende gläubige juden
in orthodoxen vierteln wie mehr sherin
gelten strenge regeln
ein musikfestival mit zehntausenden
feiernden schwulen an einem samstag
hätte hier wohl in ein desaster gemeldet
[Musik]
das hat nicht nur die regierung
eingesehen
auch liberale israelis wie der tel
aviver schriftsteller geschadet haben
ein gewisses verständnis für die
bedenken der orthodox
[Musik]
ich respektiere ihn glauben
man sollte von den ultraorthodoxen nicht
erwarten dass sie den schabbat brechen
ihr glaube ist schließlich tausende
jahre alt deshalb gibt es ja die
alternative tel aviv es wäre falsch
gewesen den esc in jerusalem
durchzuführen jerusalem ist eine
religiöse statt
es ist daher richtig dass er in tel aviv
stattfindet für den samstag des esc ist
die aufteilung daher klar
in tel aviv wird gefeiert
in jerusalem hingegen gebetet anti
musikalisch sind die religiösen deshalb
aber nicht
inzwischen hat sich sogar eine ultra
orthodoxe pop szene gebildet mit stars
wie dem zum judentum konvertieren us
rapper
[Musik]
der einziger gangsta rapper aus detroit
ist längst in ganz israel bekannt der
grund er hat bei der esc vorauswahl
mitgemacht
ausgerechnet
[Musik]
doch neben allen politischen und
religiösen debatten ist der esc auch in
israel vor allem eines eine frage des
geschmacks
ich würde eher zu einem konzert von
tschaikowsky beethoven oder mozart gehen
aber die songs wer dies sicher hören und
wenn sie gut sind sich mit
[Musik]